This is a teasmade.
And it is the most British invention.
It's a combination alarm clock and electric kettle,
which means it has two settings:
alarm,
and alarm with tea.
And like a lot of clocks that are
built into appliances,
so, clocks on ovens and microwaves,
and old style clock radios,
and central heating systems,
this clock keeps time by using the frequency
of the power grid that it's connected to.
Or would be connected to, anyway, obviously
I don't have power out here.
Power grids on this side of the Atlantic run at
a frequency of 50 hertz, fifty cycles a second.
Now that 50 hertz frequency might
rise or fall by a tiny fraction
as supply and demand affect the grid, but
over the course of days and weeks
the electricity companies guarantee that it'll
be averaged out to 50 hertz.
So clocks like this, which have to be plugged
into the grid anyway,
can use that regular 50-cycles-a-second beat
to keep themselves accurate.
Set this to the correct time, and it'll keep
the correct time as long as the power's on.
Except.
Over the last month, clocks over in Europe
have lost six minutes.
If they're connected to the
Continental European Power System,
which is one connected, synchronised grid stretching
all the way from Spain to Denmark to Turkey,
if that clock is connected to that grid,
it's six minutes slow.
This was revealed in a press release a few
days ago from the
European transmission operators' association,
who managed to write a press release that
sounded vaguely like
an angry parent who's getting close to the
end of their rope.
The problem is politics.
Serbia and Kosovo have
fallen out with each other.
That is an enormous simplification,
but if you think I'm going to try and explain
the history of the Balkan politics system
while holding a teasmade,
er, you are sorely mistaken.
Kosovo is low on power,
Serbia isn't helping manage it,
and as a result the entire European grid has
been slightly underpowered
since the middle of January.
Not by much -- but enough that the average
grid frequency
has dropped from 50 hertz to 49.996.
So clocks like this, who are expecting 50...
okay, it doesn't sound like much,
but it works out to them losing
six minutes over the last couple of months.
Problem number one is getting the grid
back up to frequency,
and hopefully politics will solve that.
But problem number two is: when it is fixed,
should the European authorities
bring the grid back to 50?
Or should they run it slightly fast
for a few weeks?
If they do, it'll bring everything back that
wasn't manually corrected...
but anyone who has already changed their clocks
will then find them
starting to run six minutes fast.
And they'll have to change them again.
They're probably going to pick
the second option, but who knows?
Fortunately for me,
I don't have to worry about it.
As I'm sure 52% of Britons
will be ecstatic to hear,
the mainland European grid is not synchronised
to the British National Grid here.
It is connected, through two undersea cables,
one under the English Channel from France,
and the other one from the Netherlands,
landing right here,
on the Isle of Grain, which is near...
nowhere. It's... it's absolutely
in the middle of nowhere.
But these cables are direct current cables,
not alternating current.
They doesn't require grid synchronisation.
So while mainland Europe's grid is slow,
our British grid is going
at 50 British cycles a second,
as Her Majesty intended.
["God Save the Queen" plays]
Our... our ovens are turning on
at the right time.
Our clock radios are remaining on time.
Our... our microwaves are
showing the correct time!
[Music stops] Or they're showing 12:00 because
no-one's bothered to program them,
but that's not the point, the point is,
[Music resumes]
the clocks may be going slow all over Europe,
but here in Britain,
our teasmades are boiling precisely on schedule.
God Save the Queen.
And god help us all.
Good!
I think that's a take.